ah it didn't work
i knew it you knew it i just wanted to
know how influential the hot shot of the
knights of fevonius is
you see the best warrior should always
be presented with the best sword
and yet here we are does the story not
make for a fitting ballad
so what are you trying to say that we're
not good enough
no that's not it more of a commentary
regarding monstat's inability to see the
warrior standing right before its very
eyes
very well looks like borrowing it is not
going to be possible
we're simply going to have to steal it
today we stand for free will
any suggestions on just how we steal it
come now speak up
that's what creep but seriously aside
from singing
i don't really have any other talents
besides if i was caught i'd have no one
to write the grave injustice of my
arrest
how can it be a grave injustice if you
got caught stealing red-handed the
things are different for you
you are the should you get caught you
would the guards here
if we managed to seize this up stop
mentioning what do you say
ah yes seems i did mention that
your point being why does your decision
hinge upon whether or not i am a god
i want to fill you in on her background
story when we get the time
huh
yes
[Music]
um
[Music]
so
[Music]
she disappeared
freeze what are you doing here
oh no we're busted
follow me
pup
ah
master d luke this is this week's
accounts
the disaster has greatly affected
business well let's hope it all ends
soon
hi we'd like to see that you're uh least
conspicuous table
um the second floor has fewer customers
you'd be less conspicuous up there
but aren't you a bard why not sit front
and center
let's save the paid performance for next
time we'll be heading up now
see you in a bit
hey keep an eye on them there's
something strange about ask
who exactly the protectors of monstat
what would you like
ah master g look have you seen two
thieves around
what happened why have you mobilized so
many guards
haven't you heard master d luke two
thieves are trying to steal the holy
liar
huh how odd isn't it the holy liar is a
treasure that was played by the god of
animals themselves
such a precious piece of cultural hair
why would one want to steal something
they can't sell off
would pay better to steal from my
sellers huh
sorry off topic believe they headed that
way
understood thank you master d luke
today i think i'll have a glass of you
can put down that bottle you stole from
behind the counter
something cold right i want answers
let me finish my drink first i'll pay
you
well with a performance it's not about
money
no need to worry when i started drinking
you were still
you want to ask he is master de luke the
boss of
the the owner of this tavern he's very
famous
by the way his dandelion wine is one of
my favorites
although most of the time i can only
afford a bottle i just heard about some
thieves from the guards for the record i
like your guts for trying to steal the
holy liar to hum even if you are
fools but we don't often get this it
wasn't us that stolen this is the hot
shot of the night
hot shot oh so you and the bart are
close friends
well despite only being a passing
traveler you've still offered your help
to monsted in its time of need
shame you joined the knights
the knights of pavonius
inefficient right from beginning to end
and towards the fatoui weak and
conservative
forget it i don't feel like talking
about it
seems you don't really like the knights
of fevonius
just differences in approach is all
i have my own hopes for this city now
answers why did you steal the holy liar
you sure you want to know it could
implicate you in the affair that's fine
i somehow always end up implicated in
their affairs
if i tell you the story it depends then
will i get paid
your reward very well let me
put on a show
[Music]
what did i just witness this is
confidential
why what say interesting give me some
time
outlander as one of blonde is the only
descript as for the bard
no problem okay
let's meet here tonight